[Music]
are y'all doing
set it up sir they're helping us pitch
our tank because we got the exact same
template our slum
we're gonna help Joe and Jess that up
there I offer to help the tip doesn't
want me to help cuz she wants me to vlog
so it's just as important ya know so we
took a trip to REI which is a outdoor
sports kind of store and bought a whole
bunch of new camping gear and it's our
first time building out this tent and
based on the wireframe it looks huge it
looks a little too big for us
but we bought this time with Isaac in
mind and so the reticle II is meant to
be a family tent but today it's just me
and TIFF join hubbed pole sections each
half of the ridge pole must pass through
a pole sleeve opening does that mean
why is everyone camping today Bart
everyone's camping today because it's my
birthday camping weekend it was that
your brother's actually yesterday it was
yesterday but it's on a weekday and if I
wanted to go camping so even though it's
probably the best timing cause we're
really busy right yeah we got so many
things stockpile while trying to
redevelop some shows while trying to
restructure some things a lot of stuff
going on it's almost like you're
building a house and remodeling at the
same time but instead of being at the
house you're out camping somewhere it
will make it count
all right so we are out in Lebec
California camping with the jkm Volvo
crew or at least a select group of us
for those I could make it is sparks
birthday weekend it was actually four in
suggester day yeah we didn't we didn't
celebrate us from working but we are
gonna barbecue shoot guns and fly drones
how much we've got we've progressed oh I
turned away for like two seconds
Wow TIFF do you think this is possible
or just you and me I think so okay is
there's like four you guys
[Music]
stick it in okay Wow yep I'm finally
useful bring the brand-new hammer that's
a big-ass entrance for a 10 this is huge
dude this is luxurious second attempt to
be this big this is for people do I
think you got four person one because we
have two dogs oh yeah that's four people
Casey got this inspired by old boy so
why take wide shot every guy retract and
we're tracking
we're tracking oh boy you're so Korean I
know we need the dogs - oh no all right
so I lent a helping hand and I stake
down 10th and it is finished now we're
all helping Joe with this 10th round -
y'all
[Music]
so while you're multitasking there Bart
it is your birthday weekend we are doing
several activities of which you find a
lot of joy in doing yes
barbecue shooting camping yes which one
is your favorite spending time with
friends I like spending time with
friends the most cuz I like shooting but
I don't like it enough where I go shoot
by myself I like camping
I don't like it enough to go camp by
myself but if I'm able to do everything
with everyone needle that's why me
though
go away so we're barbecuing and I just
realized it's Bart's birthday and I
should have brought something he
actually liked eating I'm not sure if he
actually likes jerk chicken or not but
I'm a jerk like damn it oh he likes jerk
chicken save mine on the rival chef what
are you making nothing just helping geo
set up for fire so she could do her
national dish carne asada I'm in charge
of the fun way this weekend off-roading
Oh shooty that's me are you going a team
we're building the dueling tree so when
you go shooting we can shoot this and
have some fun so basicly the military
works the thing you'll be shooting this
way and just for your school because
you'll actually hear it and you'll see
because it's white paint on it but also
once you hit it
it swings all the way around and you
shoot again over there and then you
shoot it back just like that's really
good unlike Bart you can go in a row I
get these all without missing a shot are
you saying you can do it way but I'm
saying I could do a way better than Bart
I said I could shoot way better than
Bart at front squat and like lift just
everything better than Bart
is that a 6200 cases you having fun yeah
giving peanut butter and banana oh I
like the combo Kudo for that you want
them yeah calibike is so chillaxing and
relaxing everywhere it out yummy I
cheated though I used a premade marinade
what otter smell you nobody got to know
that what do you think I thought I
smelled onion get over oh I thought I
smelled oh that is just starting for you
sir all right what are you gonna do no
dirt on the grill oh that creamy ironing
oh I did a premade marinade and I added
my own stuff desire kind of ramped up
the pre-made somewhat of a homemade at
the same time of course I can't just let
it let it be
[Music]
look so hot cooking yeah especially when
your girl's so manly is it now yeah
what's the manliest thing that I do this
this yeah so I define my manliness
through my barbecue pretty much I think
it's pretty hot when you film too just
looks like when you're directing oh yeah
you just handling the camera you're just
let me see and then I see the wheels
turning in your head your creative
wheels
yeah the more often you do all the time
yeah I should make that my day job
maybe you should be addictive uh pretty
sexy really yeah maybe I should cook
more often not sure maybe that should be
my day job I think we would starve I
think we would ever eat Wow look at you
you're cooking this never happened
yes be rare with special occasion refer
to me as chef Gio no chef do
Oh No I don't know how to read clothes
they're your drink very good relieving
maximum flight down maximum flying
distance reached you don't see it at all
I have no never
shooter ready
shooter ready look how cute and tiny
this one is this is the one that Bart's
gonna let me use picks up size in my
hand you pull it back like that it's
gonna send a bullet range going ha ha I
always get so nervous okay every tie
there's a gun in my head
yeah it's a good beginner gun or you
gotta do naked guys what a beautiful one
time I was trying to do that like that
[Music]
now I'm going to try the drawer now one
more time
how are you about to do TIFF you're
about to go off-roading oh my goodness
perfect a so cold look at Priscilla I'm
so cool hi car
all right learn from a pro Nadine you
ready I'm ready I'm ready - oh wow how
can we lock me out
oh my pinky this is so cool I've never
had a slumber party inside a tent before
[Applause]